[Music]  but i don't have a chance to get now  come on  buddy just letting you know i'm gonna be  gone cause i'm heading back east to go  to my sister's wedding wait a minute you  have a sister whoa goggles of mine man  must be ages since you've seen her what  if i go with you really let's make it a  road trip  there's thousands of things to see  which is the tiniest little taste of  death  oh dear mother  i'm guessing this is the beginning of  something great you got that right  well under the back road this is so cool  make new friends  where are you guys headed  i gotta rinse off this whole baggage  whoa  look at you  what about me  can't mess with perfection  i spy with my little eye  two quickity kitty cars  points for pageantry  [Music]  this is not what i expected  all the bumps along the road  that's what makes life worth living  buddy  [Music]  i love these i don't know come on look  you picked the last stop world's largest  tire maze  mater mcqueen mater mcqueen  [Music]  bye